hello everybody
and so as you can see
the quality of my camera is not as great
and i'm not at my
house
the reason for that is a little
complicated
i'm actually at my parents house
so hopefully this will work out okay i'm
a little worried because
we'll see we had a little i had a little
bit of technical problems
trying to kind of get this set up here
but hopefully
we will be fine
all right and so the first thing i need
to talk about is i definitely need to
apologize for all of you who are
subscribed to the website
we had some major login problems uh you
know we're working with the company
that is hosting the website but they
don't seem to have found exactly what
the issue is they thought it was a small
issue
and it turns out it's actually a it
seems like a big issue and so apologies
for that
hopefully some of you will
have had time to
send your questions to lisa i know she
posted something on the website
uh with her email
in the hopes that people would would
post but i'm seeing that there are only
six questions from the website and so
uh yeah so
that is not a good sign it means that
probably
probably a lot of you weren't able to uh
to send any questions so apologies for
that
uh and so
on top of that there's a bunch of stuff
going on do not forget
that uh starting this september
on the it starts on the 14th or the 15th
of september i'm going to be in thunder
bay
with paul vander clay and john verveicky
and a few other people to uh yeah we're
going to have a few days a conference
and some time together so don't forget
about that hopefully those who want to
come you've already signed up
what else is there there's a bunch of
stuff don't forget also the what we
recorded with jordan peterson on exodus
is going to be coming out in
november this year so it's going to take
a little while before it comes out i
might prepare some exodus material of my
own at the same time
to kind of supplement that
supplement that that uh that workshop so
well all right so let's see
so yvonne engel in the chat asks
i promise this long question is
challenging and worthwhile okay how do
we save the margin without fetishizing
it
uh i mean you usually just leave it
alone
or you you laugh
um
you laugh
you know regarding the margin that's
probably a good way
to uh to deal with it
you know and not make it your main
emphasis so
all right so as people know if you for
people who
support me at ten dollars or more you
get to ask questions in advance in the
in the q a
and uh
and then i will also answer questions in
the chat so we're going to start with
the website
cromeck jones asks hi jonathan
how in your view does the interplay
between the one and the many itself
interplay with the kinesis between
being and non-being that may require a
book length response but hey at least
it's a brief question
thank you ahead of time for subjecting
yourself to a cheers
um
and so
you could say that there's a
you if you understand it relatively it's
probably a good way to understand it
that is let's say there's relative
non-being of course we don't really have
access to
to non-being per se
you know let's say kind of the
primordial chaos but we do have access
to something relative non-being that is
that something that isn't the identity
right you could say it that way is that
which is not the identity of what what
it is we're talking about and so
you know the the way that
something relates to non-being
is usually there's you there's two ways
one is that the one
is the non-being manifests itself as
potentiality
and it manifests itself as a question
you could say
and so non-being will answer it
manifests itself also as
kind of specific so you can understand
that let's say to increase your body
yourself you have to take something
which is non-being to you that is is not
you and then you have to bring it inside
your body and that is how you
continually produce body so you could
that's probably one of the best ways to
understand the relationship between
being and not being is that
non-being presents itself as a question
to being
and then being
explicit explicit
explicitates itself is that even a word
uh in french which is explicit makes
itself explicit
into
into the question so
uh so that is probably the best way to
understand it and you can also
understand it even though you imagine a
country so you have a country with
people and so then there are people on
the outside and those people on the
outside ask something like
what about us
right and then the people on the inside
can either integrate them but they also
have to hold them off
hold them at bay to a certain extent
because non-being or the outside always
is more
than the inside and so it it it can take
over and you could say that that's how
something dies
is when
the outside let's say
comes in comes in and then levels
everything to a kind of
again a kind of potential or a kind of
flat
uh particles that have no
commonality you could say
all right so i hope that's a good
example a good good explanation
um in your recent so david flores asked
in your recent interview with jordan
peterson and greg hurwitz the
conversation revolved around his role
to what degree do you think someone
needs to be self-aware of their role to
embody it
feels like too much self-awareness would
lead to inauthentic embodiment yeah
that's a good point
um
especially if it's something like uh
an informal role that jordan
has played let's say so like a policeman
has to be aware of his role or a judge
or whatever anybody who has an official
role definitely have to be aware of
their role
in order to embody it properly
but in the case of jordan i understand
what you mean which is that we wouldn't
want
him to start imitating himself and
become like a caricature of himself
um and so in a way i think that
what we were doing and hopefully what we
were doing is pointing to something like
what we see as the highest version of
his of himself
the version of himself which
has the has most
has the best effect or has the most
positive effect on the world and so
maybe that's the best way to think of
that but i i see what you're saying you
can see that
with like especially in the
entertainment world you can see
musicians like that where they kind of
become caricatures of themselves and
they think that they're playing some
kind of cultural role
see that with actors too
so bernarda pm ask hello i'm a new
subscriber but i've been listening to
the podcast and youtube videos for a
while your content is wonderful and a
blessing to all please continue your
great work as for the question i'm
listening to your various videos on the
resurrection of christ
whoever in the christian mass cradle
towards the end it says that we believe
in the resurrection of the body
it does not appear to refer to jesus
resurrection as that is mentioned early
in the cradle what body
is referring to so i don't even know
like in the creed we say that we say the
resurrection of the body
you say the resurrection of the dead
um at least that's what we say
the life of the age to come
uh
we say we say that christ rose again
according to the scriptures
and then we say we believe the
resurrection of the of the dead but i
don't have a problem with the
resurrection of the body either
clearly the body
clearly the resurrection that the bible
is talking about is a resurrection of
the body
now
what exact type a glorified body is
maybe the way to
to see
what that what it is and so it's not
easy to fully understand what that means
[Music]
but it seems to be something like a body
which is
which does not have the kind of
resistance
that the gross material body the way we
experience like to say the fallen body
has
and so something like bodies of
you know in in in the church father they
talk about the garments of light so
something like bodies of light not light
in the physical sense
totally but these are just these are
just images to help us understand what
that can mean for sure
saint paul when he talks about the
different kinds of bodies he's clear
that there are various there are
different kinds of bodies in that
and that there are subtle more subtle
bodies you could say
um and that you know that's how a lot of
the church fathers understand
angels is that they have subtle bodies
and so you can understand
let's say you can understand how angels
have subtle bodies
actually probably an easier way to
understand how angels have subtle bodies
is
is a demon actually just because we
always understand it more easily
sometimes in the way it goes wrong for
some reason because of our nature i
guess our fallen
state we all just we kind of understand
it more easily when it goes wrong and so
you can understand that let's say a
demon that is
the principality of a
of a passion of some parasitic process
in people so let's say the the demon
that is
responsible for
let's say for for uh
for sexual desire let's say whatever uh
then you can understand that that their
body is subtle because
their their body is an influence on
other bodies and so
they they're not they don't have the
physical bodies but they do have a body
because
they they have a discernible
manifestation in the world you can kind
of see it being manifested it's not just
a it's not just a completely invisible
pattern and so
that is that seems to be what is
referred to as subtle bodies now whether
i don't think that
the way that the resurrection is
described it's not clear exactly
what exactly the body of the
resurrection is
so
i don't know because
it's not clear but it does seem to be
something
like a transmutation it doesn't seem to
just be a gross body because
it's like if you can imagine a body that
doesn't
decompose
not in a vampire way
but in in in the sense of something
which is
does not
does not have residue and does not does
not you know
i think that that's probably the best
way to understand it i i sometimes think
of something like a subtle body as
something like
a story a story as a subtle body
um saint paul talks about spiritual
bodies
so
so i don't know i don't know i don't
know exactly
but for sure
it's clear that it's that there is a
resurrection of the body that's clear in
scripture but exactly what the nature of
that body is i don't i don't i don't uh
i don't have the right insight on that
because it's also something which i
think is also meant to be
somewhat mysterious i i tend to
understand it
the way that i tend to understand it
for myself is to understand that
there is a manner in which we exist in
fullness you could say
there is a manner that if you would take
all of everything
together like all of you and then all of
your effects and then all of your
effects
effects
on multiple generations you know uh
you know even your descendants in terms
of how they
they kind of come out of your womb let's
say come out of your of your bosom the
way that it talks about in scripture
that's the idea of the bosom of abraham
and so it seems that there's a manner in
which we can kind of conceive
the matter the way in which you exist in
totality that everything about you and
every corollary and every every um
effect that you have
um and that that
that existence can be conceived of
as something like
outside of sequential time or something
like at the end of sequential time
and then that is probably the best way
to kind of understand the resurrection
that is in the end when everything ends
there's a manner in which you exist in
your totality that totality
is manifested it's judged you could say
and that includes the body if the body
is part of that the body is not absent
you're not of you're not just uh
you're not just an idea right you're not
just a thought you're not just your
thoughts you
you do have embodiment but i do think
that that embodiment
probably
probably includes something like what
you've said your works your
you know the things you've done in the
world the love you've had of others your
children
or the love you've had for your children
that's probably
also
what it means by your body that seems to
be at least the way that i understand it
but
yeah
yeah so
um
all right
so
hopefully i just didn't make everything
completely more obscure to you because
you're definitely asking what the
resurrection is is not
something that is
i don't know it's probably something i
probably shouldn't talk about at all
just because
we can have glimmers of it and insights
about it but i don't understand it
callum what do you know about games like
magic the gathering and how should
consensus
cons conscientious christians approach
game that fantasize pagan religious
practices
is simulating something that would be
wrong in real life always wrong in
itself and so i don't really know much
about the magic and the gathering stuff
um
i don't know like
it's interesting because like the
dungeons and dragon stuff let's say i
know when i was a kid there was a big
deal about dungeon dragons
and how bad it is it was just
interesting because dungeons and dragons
obviously is like a
grand great grandchild of tolkien
and so it's fascinating that it it has
been so
demonized um
so yeah sorry i don't have an answer to
you
i don't know i've never i've actually
never played that game
all right so a popper asked what is the
meaning of feeling depressed what place
does it have in christian life thank you
a popper so
what is the meaning of feeling depressed
i mean the meaning of feeling depressed
means that you don't have energy or you
don't have will or you don't have
direction
and so
you know some of it sometimes
sometimes it can just be
i mean it can be a kind of family the
best way to understand it would be like
a family curse in the sense that it's
something which is in your family and is
either physically inscribed in you know
in your
genetics or whatever or inscribed in
your story
um
i mean i think that it's something that
everybody kind of goes through it's
somewhat inevitable um
i think that it's probably actually in
those those dark moments that that is
that our faith can sometimes be that
which carries us through
because we don't have the will in
ourselves we could say to continue or to
to keep going up that hill so
yeah and i want to be careful about what
i say because
i don't want to
i mean i would say if you're depressed
like if you're seriously depressed you
need to go get help you know talk to
talk to your priest you know
or find someone who can help you
all right so ramau
asked hi jonathan could you elaborate on
the symbolism of peacocks and its
relationship to pride
the far east immortality and the
fountain of youth true of life
so the the symbolism peacocks has to do
with glory you know that's what a
peacock represents really
is glory and so because of that it uh
you know because the peacock let's say
shows its tail and its tail is is
decorated and is
and is flamboyant and glorious so that
is really in a way it's it's it's kind
of an image of glory especially because
it's the tail as well because it is this
kind of
external like this external part of the
the bird the last part that that residue
or that remainder we've talked about and
my brother talks about this this book as
well that there is a relationship
between
let's say
the crown and the tail between
that which is
the extreme
and so i think that that's what it
represents and so of course because it
represents glory then it can also
represent pride
um
and that is also its connection to
immortality
because there is a relationship between
the idea of the garment of light we
talked about this idea that that that
that your glory
your crown
is that which will
follow you or let's say will bring you
into immortality
um
and so the idea would be that if you
when you see these images like persian
images of peacocks stringing from the
fountain of life for example or being
around the tree of life
i think that it it it probably has to do
with
with that the positive aspect of glory
something like being in the garden and
having glorious bodies
that's probably what it is
all right so
we're
already
on patreon so you know
so we've got a lot more on patreon maybe
people send theirs to other to others i
don't know so sorry again for the people
on the website
um
all right so patreon emmanuel montiel
asked are there any plans to do
universal history on mesoamerica
i understand this very difficult as the
new world was entirely cut off from the
old world and so
i think there might be an interesting
thing to do about mesoamerica but we
i think we would probably do it
really from the point of view of the
of the europeans in the sense that
that's also the way in which we
understand
um
universal history
um and so but it would be interesting
because so for example when christopher
columbus arrived
in uh in the americas the first day he
said he saw a dog-headed men
and then the second day he said he
didn't talk about that anymore
so that's interesting right in terms of
understanding this relationship with the
the fully other like the fully strange
let's say
so i would be interested in maybe
talking a little about that we mentioned
a few times how the relationship between
um
the the
the american empires especially you know
in the in south america central america
that it was really like in the manner in
which apocalypto shows it like it was
the end of a world it really was the end
of their world they were like
encountering
that which would bring about the end of
their world in terms of the wars but
also just in terms of disease so this
encounter with the absolutely strange in
their case
um ended their their world really is the
only way to see it
and so
so it would be interesting to talk about
that you know but in terms of how
mesoamerica fits
in universal history i think we'd have a
very difficult time
because like you said because it was not
known or wasn't talked about
although there are interesting images of
saints
uh stories of saints that that go
west in english lore and english legends
a saint to go west and um
and find an island there
all right
so brandon burns in the comments says
it's the new it's the glorified body in
the new jerusalem and so yeah you're
right that's what it is but it
did you know it's it's easy to say that
and and not understand or not have any
sense of what that entails like what are
we talking about it's not easy to
understand
for sure the new jerusalem the
description of the new jerusalem is
being
made of precious metals of having you
know pearls for doors and all this stuff
seems definitely to be hinting at the
idea of a glorified city or a city that
is
um
that is more than just
like more than just like the kind of
gross
opaque stones that we say it's shining
it's full of light it's shining it
you know so
so it seems like there's probably some
something about the idea of a glorified
body that has to do with that in terms
of imagery let's say
all right so keenan wang asks
in the temptations christ refuses to
tempt god by exposing himself to
necessary danger for the purposes of
performing a miracle that provides his
divinity but later he seems to
deliberately delay his aid to lazarus
specifically for the purpose of
providing proving his divinity whoops do
you have any
thoughts on tempting god
in the context of these two stories
perhaps it has something to do with the
intention
in which one purposely enters death
yeah there's an interesting that's an
interesting idea
well for sure
well for sure like the one is for
himself and the one is for another that
is a big difference
and
the one would be just to save himself
and to and the other would be
was done you could say something like
for the glory of god right to to
manifest the glory of god and so that
might be the difference
but there's something yeah there's
something about
you know the idea of tempting god that i
find interesting for today which is like
even myself like i find myself asking
god
for all kinds of things as if god is
more like a
you know like your waiter or your
servant rather than the supreme
cause of all things and you know the one
who holds the universe in in
in himself
so there is something about that which
is
making my relationship with god about me
you know so there's something about that
and i think we we all kind of fall into
that of course like what does it give me
what is it
what does it do for me
hugh rose asks i've been spending some
time on the beach and i've been thinking
about its symbolism obviously it is a
peripheral space it has features that
you would expect sand castles temporary
structures formed by inverting a bucket
sand itself stone reducing multiplicity
yeah the breakdown of the rules about
what clothing it is accessible to wear
indeed having features the carnival
you're totally right
and you play in the water you know and
you also like get carried by the waves
and stuff you're right yeah that's a
good good call i need help understand
the symbols of getting a suntan to
become more desirable for becoming
sunburned
it is interesting that sunglasses are
also associated with cool
is a suntan related to ornamentation
wire protections reactions to sunlight
associated with desirability i've never
thought about that it's a really it
really is something to to think about
it i have to think about that
you know i'm wondering
i'm wondering like in terms of
in terms of the the idea of
let's say the clothing you're totally
right and in terms of the idea that that
on the beach is like an exception right
so you can be nearly naked on the beach
and then you can go back home and and uh
you know there
there isn't a direct there's like a
taboo which protects those spaces so if
you wore what you wear on the beach in a
store right it'll be totally scandalous
at a church or whatever but on the beach
it has its place and it has a kind of
function as a little moment of breakdown
on the side of the water
like the idea of the sand is really good
inside and it's a great insight
for sure the sun burns stuff is
interesting in the sense of extremes you
know with the idea that
that it's like you
it's like the nakedness of shame right
we've talked about this well it's not
shame but it's like it's related to the
nakedness of shame although it's it's
not it's fine to go to the beach but
it's not it's not the nakedness of glory
it's a nakedness of the edge something
like that and so and it's also so it
ends up being something like the
extremes where you're more exposed to
the sun
because you take your clothes off
um and so
right it has to do with how the extremes
kind of play off with each other that if
you
that if you push too hard on freedom
then you run the chance of
being it's a having a more top-down
tyranny at some point so def i think it
definitely has to do with extremes and
how extremes
need each other and manifest each other
um
the idea of sunglasses representing
cool
probably has to do just with the idea of
of you being able to see others and
others not being able to see you
right that that it is it's a kind of
power wearing sunglasses is a kind of
power where nobody can see where you're
looking and you can see
but you can see everything
why is it associated with desirability
and there's probably a really simple
answer to this
but i can't see it right now
good stuff definitely be thinking about
that
so guys i need to actually get some
water sorry i usually am ready for this
but because i'm just kind of doing this
on the
in a way that i don't use i'm not used
to i have to get the water so i'll be
right back
uh
[Music]
sorry guys
okay i know if you saw my dad probably
all right okay here we go sorry about
that
um
so aaron gazoo asked
hi jonathan my left eye is weaker than
my right and when i'm tired it wanders
off to the side what is the symbolism of
symbolism of a wandering left eye and
what would that would be that of the
right eye thanks and so
i think the best way to understand it is
is to understand that the symbolism of
the
the wandering eye
is actually is actually the left eye
like no matter which eye would be you
would have something to do with the left
eye
the left in general the idea of
awkwardness
the word let the word there's so some of
the old words like in french for example
when we use the word gauche
we can say that someone is gauche
meaning left
uh
related to the idea of being awkward and
so
aw it's like a it's like crooked right
so the idea is that the left is
is crooked it's off center you could say
the right is related to towards the
center the left is related to office
center so for sure a wandering eye has
to do with with exactly that it has to
do with so what happens
with with the wandering eye which is
interesting is that
the i the i wanders and so the
relationship between
the two gets
confused right so you you actually
aren't
seeing the same things from the from
both eyes
uh and so that confusion actually leads
to uh
let's say and over compensation from the
eye that's straight
you know to
ignore the other eye
um and so then what ends up happening is
that the wandering eye kind of vanishes
because it's not straight
so it's interesting to think about that
in terms of symbolism
of how
you know the left wanders but
if it let's say if it if it wanders too
far
then the right will
over compensate we will try to bring
things back to normal
all right so i'm here it's now asked
what is the symbolic difference in
portraying the crucifixion with nails
through the wrist versus the hands i've
seen it portrayed both ways why do it
one way or the other
well
the only reason i can imagine for for
for um
portraying christ as being as be
crucified through the wrists
would be something like you're a
modernist you're a materialist you're a
historicist
and you you really don't this like this
this this idea of cr of
christ being crucified to the wrist is
like some 18th or 19th century probably
german i forgot i don't know who it was
some scholar religions
who really wanted to show the
historicity you know like how everything
was really historical and how
historically it would have happened and
so came to the conclusion that you
couldn't nail someone through their hand
because the because there's the the nail
would just rip through
the hand and so therefore it means that
jesus was crucified through the wrist
which is
you know
whatever
the symbolism being crucified through
the hands is very powerful the idea of
being crucified to the wrist is just a
little bit irrelevant
so i'm not a big fan of that stuff
uh and also because when i see it it's
just all it's just for me it just
manifests all of what i dislike about
kind of 19th century
demythologizing or like
this kind of historicizing
um version
of the bible
that i find
most of the time this is the point
kind of like jehovah's witnesses you
know who says
who say stupid things like jesus wasn't
crucified on a cross he's crucified on a
post and so it's like okay whatever man
it's like being crucified on a post i
guess i mean a cross has definite
meaning that has been carried through
mill two millennia of a vertical and a
horizontal of you know of the stretching
out of the hands there's all this
symbolism related to the cross and so
when someone tells you well you know uh
historically either it would have been
too expensive to build a full cross so
there's really when it says across it's
just a post and it's like oh that kind
of nonsense
yeah so i really i really just like that
all right so go go ask in a recent
interview with lex friedman jordan
peterson said something along the lines
of we will need to descend into hell
first in order to reach paradise but
didn't just go down to death and defeat
death so that we would we would be
liberated and not need to go down to
hell ourselves would this not mean that
we already liberated in paradise awaits
us when we are ready to let go of our
sins what is your take on this and so
um
for sure i would say
for sure i would say like i understand
like jordan is not
jordan has really good intuitions like
he has great intuitions but he's not
necessarily let's say he wouldn't
understand the difference between death
and hell uh or like death and gehenna
you know uh
which is confused all through all
through history which is fine but there
definitely is a difference between the
idea of
death
uh or or hell in that sense and then the
idea of
the river of fire we could say that we
find in um
in scripture there's a different they're
related they're definitely related but
there's a difference but
um i think that the idea that we descend
into hell before before we reach
paradise is something that all
christians do it's called baptism it's
you know it's part of descending into
death
is something that is part of you know
when it says that those
in the orthodox church one of the major
triparias you know
to those who have been baptized into
christ we've put on christ
we have been that those like saint paul
says like if you have been baptized with
christ you have died with christ you
have risen with christ and so there's a
sense in which we participate in that
death and resurrection
um
but it also doesn't mean that there
isn't a particular
aspect of what christ did universally
and so
you the idea that sometimes you have to
go through
to hell in order to come back up you
know is something that
happens all the time right it happens
all the time and i think that for sure
in terms of
if we're talking about what's going on
now in the world it seems like we're
moving towards the death of something is
it the death of the west is it the death
death of
just america we'll probably know because
europe is is really
in trouble so it's like we're we're kind
of moving towards
the end of something
um
and so it seems at least in the
christian story that that's something
that in some ways is bound to happen
um
and so we have to we kind of have to
be ready for that so
all right so marcus shara asks jonathan
have you ever watched the david lynch
show twin peaks
many moments of it are classic murder
mystery drama but there is also many
mysterious spiritual elements playing in
the background gets off the symbolic
themes of the show
are you the black no i i've never
watched twin peaks
just never
i just and not never really not
interested in that stuff
i don't know why exactly
it was kind of like lost i remember
watching lost the first one or two
seasons
like 10 years ago i guess or 12 years
ago and uh
or maybe more than that 15 years ago
anyways doesn't matter and then
realizing really quickly that this was a
a lot of it was kind of
like
not total nonsense but really was was
not really was trying to be deep and
mysterious
but seemed to to just kind of be made up
as you go along
um and i felt that from twin peaks
although people might criticize me but i
felt that from between peaks
um and people that talk to me about twin
peaks and this stuff in there and like
really okay it just seems like a bunch
of weird idiosyncrasies pasted together
so josh asks hello jonathan hope you're
well
i've been right be seeing a ride in the
production of ar a r yeah in the last
month it's been nuts been crazy to watch
people like in the last one month or
month and a half like to watch how the
ai art has been just
exploding everywhere
curious as to what it was i looked into
and it seemed through the creation of ai
generated artworks utilizing keywords
and you type into the engine to set the
parameters of the image what
particularly stood out to me the fact
that you write the image i get the
impression that it is almost an inverted
form of icon writing and that it is
rooted in a kind of self-deification
i would love to hear your thoughts on
this thank you for your time
and any thoughts we're able to share on
this
there's definitely something about those
ai generated images which is
uncanny valley for sure
like some of it is extremely impressive
like you look at it and you're like wow
this is
crazy in terms of detail in terms of
of this the mood in terms of the
lighting
but there's always something about it
which is weird like there's something
uncanny valley about it all the time
which is that like the faces
are are like there's they're always a
little off um
or sometimes a lot off especially in the
the less powerful ones like if you use
dali mini
you can see like the faces are kind of
off
um
but some of them are i forget with the
names of their they are they're what
they are but some of them are getting
pretty
are pretty incredible in terms of the
the detail and even what they get but
there's something uncanny about the
images that they're producing there's
something which is always
like you could say
in fluidity and ambiguity and so let me
give you an example like people
have posted things like
posted images like you know
kingdom uh
the kingdom of heaven or you know heaven
ascension into heaven and and it's like
when you look at it the first glance you
get it's like wow it's impressive it's
light above it's like a mountain it's
like the spire that goes up and there's
something that looks like a cross at the
top with light and everything and it's
kind of impressive but if you just pause
a little and you look at it you realize
well that's not really a cross
and it's like
those wings on the angels they're not
really wings they kind of look like
wings they're not really wings they're
impressive
but it's it's really is this kind of
this
it really is ambiguity like this m this
rock this
the power of ambiguity i don't know what
to say but it's probably because the ai
doesn't know what it's doing right it
just what it does is that it's just
aggregating images and and keywords from
from databases
and so
it has like a sense like almost like a
blind sense of what these words and
images
are are related to
so
but it is something to definitely keep
watching it's going to get more and more
it's gonna get better in terms of detail
and it's gonna get
weirder it's gonna get scarier
because you know what's coming next it's
gonna be like ai produce videos
so yeah it's scary
i think but it's still it's so
fascinating it's definitely fascinating
so maximus maggiar asked what is the
symbolism of prohibiting priests from
dancing
i don't know
i don't know someone says i skipped
charlie's question on accident some of
the questions are are actually uh
some questions aren't there like uh
we have people that go through the
questions and edit them down so there so
there's about 50 or 60 top so that i
don't
go over like two hours um
so if sometimes your question doesn't
get through it means that either it's a
question that's been asked many times
before or it's sometimes it's too
ambiguous you know
so sorry if that happens to you
all right
so what is the symbol of prohibiting
priests from dancing i don't even know
where that is that from scripture
like uh
i don't think i've seen that but like i
mean i can kind of understand that it's
like it's
just in line with uh saint paul saying
things like you should
you shouldn't joke right paul says that
which is like okay wow like you
shouldn't you shouldn't uh make light
you shouldn't joke you know it's kind of
like saying christ never laughed
i get it you know
it's never gonna happen
in the sense that i can understand the
prohibition of it but there's also
a kind of overflowing you know
so but a priest dance like a priest
at least in theory they dance like
orthodox priests because we have this
one dance
uh
there's one dance during the um
during the wedding which is i think
called the dance of isaiah is that right
so
hopefully somebody can correct me if i'm
wrong there is a dance in the orthodox
wedding of course it's not much of a
dance anymore
it just people just kind of hold hands
and kind of walk from left to right but
nonetheless even though it's a it's very
tame
it is still supposed to be a dance so
and i can understand why people were
people weren't easy with it and and then
ended up painting and taming it over
millennia but i'm sure
sure a thousand years ago people
actually really danced
all right matthew f asks
i am curious about the symbolism of
particular places in scripture a lot of
locations
example
session bethel repeat through the key
story some places have more obvious
roles egypt but others seem more subtle
have you ever
seen the treatment of the symbolic world
of geography in scripture i'd love to
hear your thoughts about the topic and
any suggested resources that could help
eliminate these questions
yeah definitely this is definitely
important um
often you can
often you can discern
the symbolism of a place by
sure
often you can discern the symbolism of a
place by its name
you know and so
uh with it bethel means the house of god
um and then bethlehem i think it's the
house of bread
and so you will you will find jerusalem
is the city of peace
and so you will find in in the names of
the places sometimes you'll find a
relationship there's also
more to that like it would be a good
idea in matthew's book he talks about
for example
the difference between mount sinai and
mongerizim and how those two mountains
are kind of like two poles you know like
let's say evil hierarchy and a
divine hierarchy
um
and so
right the the image of the holy land
egypt as you said plays a clear role in
terms of the stranger and in terms of
the place of um
of riches but also of enslavement
you know
yeah so i think it probably really
depends but for sure matthieu's book
talks about it i'm sure even if you
looked online you could find just look
up the names of the places and you can
get a sense of what
what the different
places mean
could you please elaborate on the
pattern that culminates with the
eucharist being the real blood and body
of the lord i understand many aspects of
it but fail to see the cohesive whole
and how it relates to my day-to-day
experience
so
probably not supposed to talk about the
eucharist i think i probably talked
about it way too much
in the past
so
how does it relate to your everyday life
um
well first of all there's the idea
that
your daily life functions through memory
and so
that everything you do is connected so
let's say
you are doing homework so when you're
doing homework you are connected by
memory
to your purpose because you're not in
your purpose right you're connected to
your purpose
so memory doesn't all it doesn't just
function backwards it actually also
functions forwards because you can
forget your purpose right if you're
if you're i don't run toward the store
and all of a sudden something happens
and you forget while you were why you
were going there right so you have to
remember
things so memory is something like
the building one of the building blocks
of
experience
um and memories scaffold like they scale
up and so
so let's say you know i'm remembering
i'm remembering why i'm doing this q a
but then
the day i'm remembering why i'm doing
this q a because i because i want to be
in contact with my
my patrons with the people watching me i
want to give them a little more access
to to my thought and you open to
questions blah blah blah but it's like
that is that all that
that the memory into that is also linked
to another memory which is something
more like let's say the the vision i
have for what i'm doing you know the the
the fact
the mission that i have or whatever and
that mission
should remember and to be connected to
an even higher version which would be
something like
participating in the kingdom of heaven
something like that and so
it's important to understand that in
some ways
your life functions through the memory
of these of these
different levels
as you as you do things and so
the eucharist
is presented to you as something like
perfect memory
so it's the idea that you are f so it's
the memory is so perfect that it is it
is both identity
fully identity and also non-identity at
the same time
and so you could say
the eucharist is actually eating the
blood and body of christ like no there's
no doubt about that but it is also
being in church and eating bread and
wine
um and those two realities exist
completely
until we say something like
so it you can you can say it this way
you get to something like
the bread and wine is the body and blood
of christ so if you say it that way
you're both asserting
identity and difference com at the same
time complete identity complete
difference at the same time
and so that
you could say that that would be the
culmination of how memory works
and it would be the source of
so christians believe that it's the
source of reality that it's actually the
the secret source of things is found in
communion so a lot of i know now
secularists are gonna just be like
jonathan is just talking about magic
again
but the memory that's the how memory
works and the idea is that
there's also the relationship between
identity and sacrifice which i've talked
a lot about the idea that identity
functions through sacrifice
functions by giving itself so a way to
understand your relationship to your
purpose is memory another way to
understand your relationship of what
you're doing towards your purpose
is something like sacrifice which is
that you are
you are you're taking your best and
you're giving it up towards something
above you and at the same time you're
also
let's say casting out the the the
casting out the scapegoat at the same
time so you are always
saying you're
you're writing a book you're gathering
all these gestures in and you're giving
it towards the higher purpose of writing
the book
but you're also not
eating celery right you're not
you're you're not
trying not to be distracted and write
something else besides your book you're
trying not to do other things so you
actually have to you have to cut off
things and you have to send out
uh
something on the outside in order for
you to exist and so
the idea of memory
sacrifice
ritual
um all of this is gathered together in
the eucharist and there's so much more
like i could just talk about this all
night
but hopefully that gives you a little
idea
of ways in which the eucharist binds
your experience
so
yeah but it's never going to i'm never
going to be able to exhaust it for you
because that's why it's not an
explanation that's why the eucharist is
a participative act
and
this is also something which
is sometimes frustrating
when
when i'm when you're dealing with
talking about these difficult subjects
is that these subjects are
participations and intuitions and so
when we try to explain them
we never really capture what it is we're
trying to explain that's obvious it's
inevitable but that is just how it is
and so the way that i try to do it is as
i try to jump around and like
you say
run around the thing and then point
towards it in the middle but i can never
really
just show you the thing unless you do it
yourself unless you participate
so
so ben k asks
can you describe what the experience was
like the first time you walked into an
orthodox church
did you walk in on sunday sounds
intimidating how do you recommend
someone looking to join
go about doing it
and so
and so i
uh it was the first time i went to an
orthodox church i'd been actually
reading for
like a year and a half for like i've
been reading orthodox theologians i've
been reading about icons studying icons
sending all this and then
i
i felt like i couldn't just walk into a
church i felt like i needed a
an inn somehow and it was really
difficult at that time so i asked around
people i knew and i had a friend
who was teaching greek at mcgill
university
uh in the theological in the theology
department
and uh he said well i know an orthodox
guy
you know and so i said really he's and
he told me yeah he goes to an
english-speaking church so
i asked him if he could introduce me so
he introduced me to this person who is
now this person who introduced brought
me to the church for the first time who
is actually now a
a uh professional theologian who who has
acquired a certain amount of fame for
himself
and so
and so they they invited me this person
invited me to church we met a few times
went for coffee
discussed disgust and then finally
i went to church and it was actually
during lent
and it was during what's called the
pre-sanctified liturgy
and the pre-sanctified liturgy is an is
an evening
service where the host is pre-sanctified
so it there's there's no consecration
during the the liturgy but we do take
communion obviously i did because i
wasn't orthodox but there's the
pre-sanctified communion is a
pre-sanctified liturgy
is penitential in its tone so there's a
lot of bowing
on the ground
and uh we do these prayers of repentance
and so i walked into the church and it
was dark and it was all candles and
and then and it was
had this really
um
serious
aspect to it and then people
started to bounce the ground and i just
found it really beautiful and engaging
and very profound so
i was well the first time i walked into
a church that was it for me i pretty
much knew i was going to become orthodox
but i had also been reading for a year
and a half so
um so i would say
the best way to to go about
going to an orthodox church it depends
on your personality you could contact
the priest first try to find a church
that's in your language
considering that you know
there are churches in all kinds of
languages if you can find a church in
your language
you try to contact the priest tell them
you're going to come
so that they can maybe greet you
um but if you just want to show up you
can also just show up i mean no one's
going to people will figure out pretty
fast that you're not you're not orthodox
and so because of that they they will
probably extend
courtesy and and understanding if you
don't know what to do and you're just
kind of you're a bit lost um
but it's best probably to contact the
priest first if you want to to do that
so leon says i recently watched your
video on heaven as a response to sam
harris when you spoke about how some
figures become principles etc and i was
left wondering if you could explain
expand your view on eternal life
we just join to the principle or
principality body of christ i assume or
how do you think about this
so
so
there is a difference between
going to heaven
and
the resurrection of the of the body
let's say these things are not the same
um
going into heaven
is i think i really do think it is this
ascension it's this ascension into
into a participation
you know into the council of god right
it's a part it's the capacity that
humans have been given to become like
angels
and to be
to be uh
a chain in the in the uh you know a
part of the great chain of being that
links god to to the world
now
in that sense we are we we do have to
become a part of the body of christ like
we are a member of the body of the
messiah right we're a member of the body
of the anointed one member of the body
of
the one who unites heaven and earth
right and we are anchored to the place
to the cross we're anchored to the place
where heaven and earth
were joined together
and so
all those things
are the some ways to kind of understand
we are we must be part of the kingdom of
heaven we have to be under the rule of
heaven and participate in its
and and and ascend
into
into heaven by becoming
let's say
lower wrongs in the king not lower wrong
but like
levels of principalities in the kingdom
of heaven
so
that's what i think that is now the
notion of eternal life
at least when christ talks about eternal
life he seems to talk about
something like the fullness of life
like a life which springs completely
like a life which is full and is not
limited is not limited by time it's not
limited by space
a life which is com which is complete
you could say and so i think that that's
probably the best way that i would
understand eternal life and the idea is
that you don't get eternal life after
you die right you get eternal life you
can you have access to eternal life now
you have access to the kingdom of heaven
now and that's things that these are
things that jesus says himself like it's
not i'm not making this up
but there's a manner in which
in the fullness of things you know when
all is revealed and all is gathered
together
in the end
then we will also experience the
fullness of that um
but that's as close as i get to like
giving you an explanation
if you want me to give you like a
mechanical physical explanation of what
that
will be or what that is in terms of
what happens to you after you die
you know
i think the the the images that the
church uses in terms of understanding
the idea of a judgment after you die
is a really great way to understand it
i do believe there seems to i think
there seems at least in my understanding
this is speculation on my part but
i think there is like almost like an
identity between
personal judgment and cosmic judgment
that your end is the end right it's like
when you die
it corresponds to the end of all things
and so there isn't this sense because
people always ask okay so
you know if the sen if the saints are
dead and they're
and christ is not returned and we're not
we haven't reached the the fullness
of things the play roma or whatever
then
what that how is it that that we can
pray to them like are they are ready in
the kingdom like what is going on and i
think that if we understand that that
all ends
coincide that the end of all of each
thing
culminates into the end of all things
then it's not as it's not as
bothersome right you could say that they
are answering your prayers
from the kingdom they're answering your
prayers from the eschaton
because
in a way the eschaton is
is the end of things is always
there hidden you could say in the world
it's not just something that's happening
in the future
yeah
so
sorry man why you guys are asking really
difficult questions that i think is
gonna just confuse everybody
let me look into the chat a little bit
yvonne engel asked what is the
relationship between the divine darkness
and the divine feminine does it allow
partitioning of identity by obfuscating
the rest
i don't know
the word divine feminine is is just a
weird expression i know jordan peterson
uses that
yeah i'm not i don't see that expression
anywhere
in the in the father's or the tradition
divine feminine i mean there is this
idea of sophia a little bit that people
talk about but it's always kind of
iffy and and a little off-key like
yeah
so
okay the man founded sarah gosa ask
hello jonathan thank you for your work
what is the symbolist symbolic
importance of those who give
body to an ideology party ultimately
being consumed
by its once
it is ascendant or fully formed
thinking of marxists and gulags or
getting purged
is betrayal a special punishment or is
it just how egregors work or maybe both
it seems aggregaors need your attention
until they are embodied enough to eat
you
then they just eat you
so i think that the best like when we
talked about with with uh john rivegi we
we clarified a little bit some of the
terms because people are using these
terms a little i mean we're using them
pretty loosely because we're trying to
understand
you know what it is that transpersonal
intelligence looks like or what it is
that these transpersonal agencies look
like so the idea
the idea would would be to understand
this type of thing where an ideological
as akin to uh
as an obsession or a passion as akin to
a parasitic process in your self
but then at a social level
which is that
the parasitic process seems to
to devour everything until it exhausts
like a parasite devours its its by the
prey
until
it consumes it and then it then it then
itself will die or itself will have to
find another host
and so that seems to be the opposite
of
let's say the body of christ or or
the way in which bodies stack up in
terms of the individual the family and
the community you know in the nation and
the the church and the in in christ like
how those actually build up each other
and that the one is the building blocks
of the other so the you know healthy
individuals are the building block of
healthy families and healthy families
are the building blocks of healthy
communities et cetera et cetera et
cetera that the ideological
bodies the ones that go like the way
that marxism went
is that they devolve and they self
they eat themselves
because they're not
they're not giving up to another good
and so they tend to actually devour
their own
participants and it has to do with
revolution a lot of it has to do with
revolution
that if you understand how marxism and a
lot of these ideologies are
revolutionary
which means that what they do is that
they try to
take power for themselves like they're
related to pride and revolution so you
have i don't know the bourgeoisie and
then the bourgeoisie says you know these
aristocrats they should be our leaders
we should just get rid of them and take
their power and so you have something
below that remove that which is above
and then takes the place and so
in the normal in the normal hierarchy of
beings and the ones that i talked about
in terms of individual family etc you
could say something like legitimacy
flows from above
you know
and so you get your lead
so you get your name as a person from
your father
you know and then the the family is
legitimized by higher participations in
higher order
higher order beings
but in terms of of this what happens
because you have self legitimate
legitimacy where someone takes power for
themselves then they
don't have legitimacy from above so the
only thing they can do is to then
consume those below them
or be consumed by those below so it's
like think about it right so this is
actually marx's
take marks his vision so you know the
you could say something like the
aristocrats kill the king
the bourgeois killed the aristocrats
then the proletariat killed the
bourgeois
and so
it's this revolution but if you want to
stop it the only way to stop it is you
have to purge everybody below you so
this is seen in the story in hessian's
theogony for example so
cronus castrates his father
he becomes the head god and then what
does he do he eats his children
because he knows that
this now that he has
his legitimacy is gone
then he's the next he's next in line
they're coming to castrate him too or to
kill him and so he has to devour his
children so that is
that is how parasitic processes
work
is that they
they don't build towards higher
participation
um and so they they move into chaos and
tyranny they tend to move towards chaos
and tyranny
all right matthew mull brandon says hi
jonathan do you think secular
architecture
or urban form how cities are laid out
has real importance to their enchantment
progress project if so what are one or
two things you could change in modern
cities
so yes i definitely agree and you know i
think that what's interesting is that
there are
people that are thinking about that now
i'm actually i collaborate a lot with
someone whose name is andrew gould
you've probably seen him on my channel
if you've been paying attention for a
little while andrew gould is a building
designer
who lives in charleston and he works
with other
contractors and designers to create
what's called the new urbanism
which is a movement towards a
rehumanization of the city
by
um
by making buildings that are
only a certain height
by making uh walkways by having centers
like parks and places of meeting you
know there are a lot of ways in which
these new urban urbanism people are
working there's a book that was written
by i think it's published by princeton
it's called charleston fancy and it
looks at this project
the this project of kind of of a new
urbanism of creating
new neighborhoods so for example there's
a um
there's a um
the first church that andrew built is in
a little neighborhood called ion near
charleston
it's not in charleston but it's it's
just a little outside of charleston
and uh in this neighborhood they created
right they the developer wanted to have
a church for example
wanted to have something like at least
one church and have something like
centers he also made the streets
extremely narrow so that
cars would have to let each other pass
in the street and you think that's
really annoying but what it forces you
to do is to constantly being in contact
with others because you you can't have
people parked and two cars
crossing if people are parked on the
side then you have to let others go and
you have to to kind of move across and
so
all these little things were done to and
you see that in the south i saw quite a
bit of that in greenville
for example they redid all of the
downtown area they removed the
overpasses
they opened up the downtown to to to
walking they made a massive park near
the river
and uh and it works right it creates a
kind of
so i think that
these are small steps but i think that
for sure if we're
moving towards re-enchantment there will
have to be
a rethinking of space at a human level
yeah except for the dark enchantment
that one's going to happen on the
metaverse will create something like
that in the metaverse
you know human scale
architecture and uh community
when you're wearing your glasses
but then when you take them off you'll
be living in a pod right it'll be eating
the bugs or whatever
all right so blake straight says
i'm officially part of the body i took
orthodox communion this past sunday
congratulations break the blade it's
good to get to hear that lord of god
quite an experience that you were partly
responsible for thank you well all i can
say is glory to god for that
what is the relationship between the
blood of christ and the holy spirit it
seems that if the blood is what gives
the body life that one could say that
the holy spirit is the blood running
through the body church giving it life i
know they're different but i do not
understand where the difference lies
thank you brother and so you're right
there is definitely a relationship you
know
in the scripture it says that the the
blood is the spirit of the body that
blood is the
is the life of the body and so there is
definitely a relationship between
the spirit and and the blood but i
wouldn't
never heard of it
of a technical relationship
but i definitely
see that there's an analogical
relationship for sure
so nicolas says why is the bible written
as text only it's fine for the
storytelling part of it but when we get
to the list of rules about the
sacrifices list of lineages and
instructions on how to build an artifact
then some spreadsheets graphs
architectural drawings or illustrations
could really help why do we start using
images only after christ's resurrection
so
i mean
i mean i would say that it in a way it's
not completely so yes the bible but it's
like the hebrew tradition was not just
the bible it was also the actual temple
itself and the tabernacle and the
practices and so the practices are
described in the text but they were
alive in the people and in the
traditions and in what you know so you
could say like in the scripture
the description of a cherub for example
in scripture
is difficult but i'm sure people knew
what a cherub looked like back then they
knew
when it said sometimes it says some kind
of ornament or some kind of thing
and people just knew what it was because
they lived in that world and they had
that understanding and so i think that
that's what it is i think also because
because text is
how can i say this
text
is more easy to
transmit and to remember
because you can
you can transmit it more closely to
you don't have to ask yourself so much
like what is the detail and what is
tradition whereas images are more
flexible like there's a lot more
flexibility
um
so there seems to be a lot about that
but for sure also
the fact that we use images after
christ's resurrection has to do with the
incarnation itself because
they are for sure there are prohibitions
against images in the old testament of
course there were images but there there
definitely is a suspicion and some
prohibition against some kind of images
in the old testament so that's that's
one of the reasons why
christianity is far more imagistic
than the bible
so random vern says any thoughts on why
people are choosing more traditional
forms of worship
example extraordinary form of the roman
writing catholicism orthodox liberty
so
i mean it's interesting i guess some of
you saw that video i didn't watch the i
watches clips of it that video of uh
it's the name of that actor sorry guys
that after that converted to to
catholicism
yeah it shows you how much i really care
about these things but anyway so
these major actors that converted to
catholicism
and uh and he talked about right away
went straight to like you know latin
mass and everything so i think that it's
because
you know one of the problems that's
happened in the past
century is that the churches
have tried to accommodate the world
they've tried to say well let's
let's get closer to the world so that
you know we're more we can gather more
people have more influence but what
happened is they actually watered
everything down and then
people started to see less of a
difference between
their boring life going to the club or
you know hanging out with their friends
and going to church and so
the idea that church was a space
the reverence that god is supposed to
cause in us like the sense that god is
above us that
we are participating in something so
much greater than us and and so much
more
so much more lofty
than us is lost in the guitar
church services in the rock concert
church services so i think that people
it's like if i'm gonna go to a if i'm
gonna go to a concert why would i go to
church i mean they're not as good as the
rock concerts i might as well just go
see
you know see
a rock band instead of going to church
so
now i think that people are realizing
that wait a minute like
if i'm going to be a christian like why
would i why would i want to why why
wouldn't i want the most
the most of it like why wouldn't i want
the one that has the deepest meaning and
has the most interrelationship and has
the most it's closest to its own world
view that is the closest in expressing
christianity as a worldview not just as
a bunch of moral tenets or as a bunch of
sentimental
uh relationships but as a way of being
in the world
and of participating in how the world
lays itself out i think that's the
intuition people have and that's why
they're going towards traditional
christianity
and i think that most people at least
that i know that convert to catholicism
will go there
and i think that that's possibly one of
the reasons also why people
convert to orthodoxy
so um
what happened here
kind of got confused
right so
muhammad
hi jonathan boswell what are your
thoughts on dating apps in our current
environment do you advise christians to
use it as a means to meet a significant
other and so
i would say no i do not advise
christians to use it to meet a
significant other
but
if it happens then that's fine you
should be happy like i mean if that's if
you meet people online
that's fine like i think i think it's
the whole online thing is is difficult
but
especially the apps because the apps are
there's like consumer
aspect about these apps which is just so
disgusting and so it's like a christian
wants to meet their wife but they're
like consuming
pictures of girls and picking them you
know it's like oof my goodness there's
something about that which is of
difficulty but also i understand people
suffering because because there's
less and less of an opportunity to meet
people people are becoming more isolated
so i would say
you know i would say
soft no
but
sometimes you do with what you can right
you do with what you've got so
so ross alexander says can you please
for the defined marginal infringe as it
relates to the upside down world that
you talked about many times on your
podcast what does it look like and how
do we know if i'm how do i know
if i'm acting marginal or french kind of
like the frog in the proverbial pan of
cold water that gets heated up i get
complacent in what i see and things that
are not normal become normal and so
now
the first thing to understand is that
when i talk about the fringe and i talk
about the exception and i talk about the
marginal
um
it's not a strictly moral thing it's not
it's not as if
it's just center back center good fringe
bad
it's not as simple as that you know it's
like uh
the center has its danger
which is pride
and the fringe has its danger which is
dissipation
and the center has its
strength which is origin which is
meaning which is
and the fringe has its advantage too
um
which is something like
the question the multiplication you know
the particular
and so
the question is rather
how so
how to act in this different
circumstances like you said how not to
be
possessed in a bad way by the situation
so
so like i've said like in some ways
there's a time for the carnival
uh it's just that you have to be careful
not to
confuse the carnival
with like there's time to eat dessert
but you have to be careful not to
confuse dessert with the meal
if you if you can if you confuse dessert
with a meal
then you're going to get sick and you're
going to throw up
right it's like that if you want a nice
little image of the fringe throwing up
is an image of that as well
um
and so so the marginal looks like
the strange it looks like
confusion of identity mixture of
identity
it looks like um
humor
upside down behavior
uh it can look like uh
bodily
stuff body stuff right uh
all the way to like scatological humor
and all that kind of stuff so all that
is part of the fringe of the margin
um
yeah the clown
and so
the idea is
i think that for sure right now
because the fringe is so prominent and
is like is so overwhelming
it is it is really dangerous to be
dissipated into it
so we we definitely
should arm ourselves against the dangers
of the fringe right now and we should be
able to find purpose right that's why
jordan peterson is so successful because
he says meaning
you know purpose that's how you get out
of it responsibility these are all nice
little images of the center
responsibility meaning purpose direction
these are the things that will
that will heal you from you know the
excessive turning that we're part of
um
but at the same time you also have to be
careful not to become
prideful and overly
overly harsh and so
that's something that i see i think i
see in the the kind of rad trads right
the radical traditionalists that you see
also both in catholicism and in
orthodoxy is that
in a normal and understandable reaction
to the clown world
they move towards something which is
let's say totalizing and is uh
and is dangerous in terms of pride so
hopefully that
helps to understand
so brandon bailey says hi jonathan hope
as well is there a meaning behind the
holy spirit being said across the
horizontal plane when crossing yourself
um
i mean
you could i mean i think that this is i
really hate doing the trinitarian
theology but you you do
see some theologians who talk about
how
the god
the father the son and the holy spirit
is
you know the the
something like the bond of love between
the father and the son you kind of see
that
in different theologians
um
something like that maybe that that can
help so it's like the father above the
son below and then the holy spirit
connecting them together
but this is totally speculation on my
part i've never thought about it
enough to really give you a good answer
so sorry guys i'm getting like exhausted
more
quickly than usual it might also be
because it's like
it's really hot
so abe asks hi jonathan i'm wondering if
you have any thoughts on the topic of
animal suffering not suffering inflicted
on animals by humans but rather the
physical pain and mental anguish that
animals experience in the wild due to
violence starvation illness loss fear
etc how do we understand this if animals
were created or evolved before humans
and the chance to bring death into the
world with sin i understand that it's a
question that many have struggled with
including c.s lewis in the problem of
pain any thoughts you have
are much appreciated
so
what i'm gonna say is is actually like
is really like pure
speculation on my part and something
i've been thinking about quite a bit and
it's it's related to
so
so saying effort the syrian describes
paradise
in a way where
you have the mountain of paradise and
then you have the wall of the garden and
then below the garden are the animals
and
they're outside of the garden
so
and and if you read saint gregory nissa
what you'll see is that
there's a direct relationship between
the fall
and the garments of skin
and animality
and that animality
at least in segregate
seems to be
a symbol a symbol of
death the hairy garments of death itself
of
of dying of
being a slave to the lower things a
slave to the passions a slave
to all of this and so
so there there seems to have been
at least there seemed to possibly be in
this in the story
an intimation of death already there
or a possibility at least because
how if god says to adam and eve to eat
of this fruit you will die
i mean he's he's saying if you eat this
fruit you will die so
death
needed to have been had to have been
understanded
somehow by them
and so
so yeah so this is these are the things
that are mulling around in my mind sorry
i'm not coming to like a direct
a direct conclusion but there seems to
be
at least some possibility in my vision
that
that there's a relationship between
death and outside the garden
at least already and you see it in the
church fathers
so
sorry
sorry
if that's not clear enough
but i don't have a full solution to that
i'm just kind of thinking out loud right
now
so why lawrence says what is the
symbolism of the separation of church
and state and so
i mean it's interesting to think about
it and it's interesting to think also of
the differences between the way that the
western
society did it and the east and the east
did it so
in the seventh ecumenical council for
those who don't know the seventh
ecumenical council people think that
it's mostly about icons that it's mostly
about the restoration of icons and in
some ways it is at least
in the more more
external way we celebrate it but the
seventh-day communicator council
is also about the liberation of the
church from the state
because until then and the iconoclasm
was driven by byzantine emperors so
byzantine emperors were the ones who
imposed iconoclasm
on the church
and this comes
as a kind of culmination we could say of
emperors meddling directly
in church affairs
and so
when when uh
the seven minute ecumenical council
arrives one of the things that is
declared in the council
has a lot some of the things that are
have a lot to do with
how
the church is independent from the the
the emperor or the state that the church
has its own
has its own capacity to make decisions
now
at least in the byzantine empire that
separation did not mean
full and complete separation as in not
talking to each other
right as in like a divorce right so it's
like the separation of church and state
didn't mean divorce it meant
like a husband and a wife like two
separate people with their own
with their own needs desires and goals
that could work as a
symphony together towards what they had
in common
and so
and so that is the way it was conceived
of in the byzantine empire and then in
the russian
tradition as well
so that's the difference so it's
different than what we see in the west
where at some point it becomes not only
the divorce but like a bad divorce right
where
the the emperors and the uh the german
emperors and the popes are fighting and
you know the
we have three popes at some point
because the the king of france
wants his own pope and it's like woof
yeah so
so ex perez says hi jonathan i was
wondering if you saw any correlation
between old testament category of
nephilim and our modern status
of celebrity both seem to direct
attention to themselves as objects to be
worshipped it is merely a difference of
scale or is it the more to it
is it is there more to it that i'm
missing
p.s i just got god's dog in the mail and
i just want to say excellent start to
the series pray that god makes straight
the way before you and the rest of you
the team and i look forward to hearing
news about the next issue as soon as you
are able
so thank you
x or xavier or x perez so so just before
i answer your question so
a lot of things have changed in the gods
dog situation my goodness i probably
will have to make an announcement to uh
to the supporters that supported the
first book you know most of the books
are delivered now unless you are in
europe if you're in europe you sadly
still have to wait
because
because we're struggling with some tax
issues and it's super complicated
because it seems like we shouldn't have
to deal with them but we are dealing
with them so because of that we're
looking for solutions and the shipping
companies looking for solutions to be
able to center books there so that's one
the second is that
cord nielsen who was the artist in the
first book
finally decided that
it was too risky for him to quit his job
and to
to do this you know
he he has healthy shoes in his family
and it's just you know it's really hard
in the united states
if you don't have health insurance so
it's something that kind of made him
hesitate and also
made it that his needs were probably too
high for what was possible in terms of
the the working full time on the book so
so so we were caught a little bit
wandering and not knowing what to do and
so we asked around and we tried to
figure it out until finally we did find
a new artist for
god's dog too his name is matt sheehan
you can look him up online
he has worked for dark horse he has a
more kind of europe he's an american but
he has a more european drawing style
he's also orthodox and he
he goes to um the same parish as jacob
russell those of you who've been in
symbolic world for a long time
know who jacob is and so so it's cool
it's going to be very different his
style is very different took it took a
while for me to kind of like all right
to work with him and to see how we can
make it happen but it's going to look
more like uh like a like a like a kind
of old-school adventure
comic it's going to be more more
realistic
you know
more um
yeah it's going to be more realistic
less cartoony um and so yeah i'm really
looking forward to seeing what he what
he puts together but his style is very
detailed and is and like i said it's
more realistic so it's gonna take a
while so sadly we're looking at probably
a year before we get it done
um but
it's definitely part of
this is something that i'm not giving up
guys like i'm going to keep pounding at
this you know we're going to keep doing
it we're going to get it we're going to
get it done so
and uh and all of you who got the book
do not forget to scan the qr code and
get your god's dogecoin
you know oh man
jamie
who who uh
who programmed this did an amazing job
like the experience of getting your
god's dogecoin is beautiful it's like
super slick this is an amazing little
video that looks at the symbolism of
god's dogecoin made by symbolic memes
there is uh
you know it's like there's it's
hilarious it is hilarious and you have
that nice little gaz doge going in your
wallet with the
seventy 7777 uh coins so it's a lot of
fun and uh you know and within the next
year we're gonna start to think of
things we can play around with
to uh to to to create something that we
can pull our
coins towards you know maybe you know a
story that's broken up so people have to
kind of pull the pages or something i'm
still thinking about it but uh but we're
gonna have some fun with those coins so
um
so don't forget to do that
all right and so
i need to answer your question now so
what is the relationship between old
testament uh the nephilim and modern
modern status of celebrity there's
definitely a
a relationship in the sense of the gods
right in the sense of the
that's why we say they're stars right
that's why we say they're idols we
actually use those terms to talk about
them
um and so they become like guiding
lights and people align themselves on
them and so in some ways they really are
like
the
kind of
degenerate or really
low virgin of the old god so if you look
at
if you look at the way in which so look
at i watch like a beatles concert right
and it's like when you look at what
happens what has happened during a
beatles concert and like women losing
their senses and like becoming ecstatic
and like you know ending up you know
shaking on the ground crying i mean
it looks like something from a greek
tragedy right it looks like
the women in the forest you know
in the bakki like the the the women
cavorting in the forest like that's what
it looks like and so there's definitely
something related to that but it is a
very lame and pale
version of a religion these celebrities
it's
it's pathetic um
but yeah i mean people need gods right
it's like if you get rid of them
they're gonna turn into johnny depp or
mick jagger it's like
david bowie or whatever it's pretty
pathetic
but you know
that's where we are
so sean rigaldo asked i was reading a
conversation you had with jiffy marceau
about the danger
of symbolism and being overwhelmed by
meaning can you protect yourself from
becoming overwhelmed
by symbolism how can you protect
yourself by becoming overwhelmed
symbolism
um
i think that relationships is really
helpful having friends being in a
community being in a church
and then also always
putting your symbolic intuitions
testing them
against the tradition of the church
testing them against your friends
testing them against
the the your priest your confessor
whatever so that
you can
[Music]
and that hopefully that if you do that
then
then you'll get enough signals if you're
going off key like you get enough
singles if your interpretations start to
get like you know just
drunkenness or something like that which
happens all the time like i
you know i've met people that
you know they they lost the plot in
terms of
loose associations and it's kind of
losing themselves in these associations
so
so i think that that's probably one of
the best ways to to do it and um
and i would say also like come back to
the
the things you're interpreting let's say
so it's like you're interpreting a bible
story
you know make sure that what you're
saying a counter all the aspects of the
bible story
that
doesn't
just focus on one thing because that's
what happens with people a lot of people
get lost in symbolism is that they they
find this weird little thread and then
they fiber focus on it instead of of
backing away and moving in and kind of
doing this dance where you're noticing
the bigger pattern you're noticing the
smaller one you're seeing how they're
embedded with each other they hyper
focus on one thing
um
and then they they start to see things
which which are
are not there or are marginally there um
so
hopefully that's enough
so nick egginsburger says hey jonathan i
was wondering if you could recommend any
books or other media to someone without
access to a church wanting to convert to
orthodoxy
so
man
i should have it on oh father
father andrew
father andrew uh
damick
put up a website just i hope somebody
maybe in the chat would have it
put put something in the website in the
online like a kind of introduction to
orthodoxy um
maybe we could put it in the the
description
once
once we're done with this because i
don't know if i could be able to find it
right away it's really good it's like a
very simple
nice little website that that kind of
takes you to
just a basic understanding and can help
you to connect you to
to actual priests into an actual
community
um yeah i'm not gonna find it right now
so sorry father andrew
and so he sent me this to me a while ago
all right sorry so we'll put it in there
we'll find it and we'll put it in the
description so check back tomorrow
or in the next few days and we'll have
um
we'll have a
description of that all right so
let's just get back to oh
sorry
all right okay
so alex
solento says hey jonathan can you talk
about andrew tate
i know this question sounds like a joke
but in all seriousness the amount of
influence that he holds is increasing
every day why are people attracted to
his ideals and so i don't know
[Music]
i don't know um
i don't know anything about andrew tate
sorry guys i mean
i think he's a i guess he's a he's like
a hyper masculine
guy
and kind of a masculinity guy
but i don't sadly i don't know about him
i don't know what to tell you i don't
think i've ever seen any video of him
um i mean
just in general like you could say that
this kind of hyper masculinity here this
this
these hyper masculine movements that
we're seeing right now
are just inevitable like they're
inevitable because
the push on the other side is so strong
that
why wouldn't that happen like why
wouldn't why wouldn't that
that that kind of uh idea happen in
terms of success in women and making
money and being rich and all that stuff
it's not that's not what masculinity is
at least it's not what the ideal
masculinity is in any normal culture
but i get it i know why people are going
there because they men have
these drives and this arrows right these
desires towards success and towards
you know
towards women towards and and the whole
world is telling them right just watch
porn and jerk off and it's like
you know
they they want more like they want
something and so i understand why these
kind of characters will pop up and will
have the type of influence that they're
having but
you know i don't like i said and i also
don't know enough about it i just know
what people are saying about him
so hopefully i'm not misstepping and
even in what i've already said
so silas allen says what is the
symbolism of food being perishable
oh it has to do with that chaos like the
relationship between potential and chaos
like the line between potential and
chaos is pretty thin
so potential becomes chaos uh
that's that's all that's all it is you
know and it's like uh
there's there's there's chaos and then
in chaos there's
there's potentiality which is available
to you
but that
that is not uh how can i say this
like i said the relationship as it moves
back down into
absolute chaos is um
is possible
all right so john says what is the shape
of time is it a straight line a circle a
cone
yeah i like the cone i think a cone is
an interesting idea
for sure time the idea of the time is
the straight line it's just it's just
this is just
weird nonsense and it you see it like
these i don't even know where it's from
these christian theologians and you'll
hear them
say it's like well you know the
conception of time and the bible is
linear now the pagans had circular time
and the bible has linear times like what
that's just a lie that's not true which
is not true you hear like this
perspective of history you hear people
say that all the time like what are you
talking about it's not what it is
clearly there's circular time in
scripture but it's not it's not like a
repeating circle it's it is something
like a cone you could say or something
like a a circle which is always
different so it's so it doesn't actually
say that the circle doesn't actually
join up to the to the beginning of the
other one it's above it or below it or
it's you know it keeps going
um and so there's both
circularity and direction at the same
time
so there is a scent in which towards
we're moving towards the eschaton but
the idea that that isn't also a kind of
circularity and moving up so that's why
in the eschatological image of the final
image of the heavenly jerusalem that
it's clearly related to
eden it's clearly related to the garden
and so
it is in a way a return but a
fulfillment at the same time so
yeah so i like the cone image is
probably probably the one i would feel
closest to
um so hello jonathan i'm currently
reading the language of creation i was
thinking of buying this book for my
father and brother i'm a little hesitant
because our family has always read
through the bible through a lens of
baptist products and theology i know
they will say this is interesting but
where is it coming from essentially what
is the authority for the interpretation
to be honest
i'm still trying to answer this question
for myself please let me know your
thoughts
and so
i mean i know what to say like mature
really decided to write his book that
way for a reason
you know because he wanted to present
something which was simple and pure and
and distilled you know and so the very
even the layout of the text you know
is is extremely distilled um and so
that's what he wanted to do now
i mean does it give you insight into the
text like is it giving you insight that
you feel like it's giving you insight
that contradicts something that you read
in the in the church fathers or in
i don't think so
and so
you know where does it come from i it
definitely comes from metoo's reading a
lot of biblical commentaries in the past
20 years uh you know 25 years or
whatever uh and also
him just meditating on scripture for a
very long time
but he he
he wrote it for that reason so i
understand a lot of people i'd say
that's the main criticism about his book
that's what it is but
i think it also means that his book will
have a longer
a longer lifespan than a lot of these
modern uh like exit
exegetical works that are filled with
footnotes and
comments on the greek and you know like
caveats about different strains of text
like i think all those
all those biblical commentaries will
just vanish into the
into the chaos and and i think that
matthieu's book will
will probably have a far greater in the
end and longer
influence so
so then maybe the answer is
just wait until the early adopters have
fully digested it and it starts to
actually seep into his church without
him knowing it and then
by the time it's kind of seeped in then
then he'll read it and he'll think it's
just obvious
that's the thing about symbolism is that
in some ways it underlies or it precedes
even
some of the theological interpretations
we have it's like it's it's such a basic
language of structural language that
so that's one of the solutions
all right stephen young says hello
jonathan i was looking into the abraham
and isaac story and something i noticed
was the leaving of the donkey and the
two young men at the bottom of the
mountain before abraham and isaac ascend
my question is is this supposed to be a
symbolic dichotomy of the inside and
outside representing an ontology at the
bottom of the pyramidal structure
meaning yes definitely that's definitely
what it is and i really don't see
what else it is because the donkey is
impure
animal and then you know the
sacrifice the the ram that they find at
the top of the hill is a pure animal
and so you would never sacrifice a
donkey
so it's also the the donkey the servants
the donkey
these are marginal in terms of your
identity so definitely i think that's
definitely
for the same reason that you have the
golden calf
at the bottom of the hill and at this
for the same reason you have this like
shedding of people as as moses goes up
the hill um
in the story of exodus i think it's
related to that
so stephen bishop says hi jonathan can
you comment on the meaning of the death
of judas in acts 1 18. now this man
bought a field with the reward of his
wickedness and falling headlong he burst
open in the middle and all his bowels
gushed out
in is this an image of judas having too
much body and you're probably hosting
heaven i christ
also how does it relate to the gospel
description of him having hanged himself
i would love to see a video on the
symbol they don't do this more broadly
so i think that
the two stories of judas's death
emphasize two different aspects of the
symbolism of judas
one is
that he is an antichrist
and so in being an antichrist
he
he hangs on the tree so we
there's a direct relationship between
hanging on a tree and the crucifixion
because in the old testament
it talks about just hanging on a tree it
says a just man
does not the just does not hang on a
tree just men will never hang on a tree
um and so there's a whole trickery there
there's actually an early image one of
the first images of the crucifixion we
have fifth century is an image where you
see christ on the cross on one side of
the image and judas hanging from the
tree on the other side like in opposites
kind of facing each other and so it is
this interesting idea of
you know
the christ and antichrist and how in
some ways
judas is the unjust man who hangs on the
tree
and you could say christ is the one
who becomes unjust to hang on the tree
you know who becomes sin to hang on the
tree
it's very it's very very mysterious but
it's a very powerful relationship now as
for this image
this this is if you want i mean this is
the stuff that we talk about all the
time right so what happens to judas
he falls upside down
he hits his head
on the ground so he flips
he flips upside down he hits his head on
the ground
and then
his middle burst open
and then
the dirt his filth is exposed you know
for for the world to see it's like
yeah
it's the end of a world folks you know
it's like if you want to understand it's
the end of the world so it's like it
it's too
you could say it's like two images of
antichrist like two ways to talk about
antichrist
um
[Music]
yeah
all right so brandon byrne says can
israel jerusalem be viewed as a symbol
of both the church and an individual
believer and the answer is yes
for sure that's why israel
is both an individual and uh and a
person a country like it's both israel
is both an individual and
and a people and so so there is no
there's no
it's not speculation that there's that
you can see it as both an individual and
uh and the community so
yes
um
all right so connor mitchell says
have you ever thought about the
symbolism surrounding bull riding as a
genuine pre-modern folk tradition i feel
as if it holds some notable patterns to
it
such as the fact that the writer must
remain
for eight seconds or the nature of the
clown at the periphery distracts the
bull after the writer falls off
specifically speaking i'm interested in
how well you believe it maps onto
mythological patterns and stories
with the bull and writing represent in
the ritual yeah
and with discipline masculinity as
expressed by the writer triumphing over
wild and attained masculinity
represented by the bull for an infinite
eight seconds be an appropriate
understanding
so i don't know about the eight seconds
like i've never
maybe but for sure it definitely has to
do with mastering potentiality like
that's definitely what i have to do it's
like it has to do with in some ways a
little world where the writer and the
the mount right so the
idea and the
body you know the head and the body
come together in a way that
it's very difficult for the
for the writer to master the amount
right it's like walking on water or
something like that
and so
they have to do it for a cycle so eight
is maybe the eight is related to the the
seven plus one that is possible but for
sure whatever it is it has a certain a
cycle in order to kind of show that that
you've mastered this right
um
and so definitely and the clown for sure
like the clown that then drags the
let's say that
that distracts the body right or that
that pulls the
the danger away from the writer is like
that's such a great imagery yeah
yeah it's a nice little microcosm i
really wonder how old those traditions
are
you know
they're probably really old but maybe
it's hard to find traces of them
all right so so stephen young says
what was wrong with my patreon question
to comment i don't know stephen
um
there are a few things there there are a
few possibilities sometimes people also
put them in too late you know that's
also a possibility and sometimes it's
just because there's too many and we
have to prune some so it's not that your
question is bad it's just that
you have to get to a certain amount so
that we don't go over to if i go over
two hours i just become a puddle you've
probably seen these older q and a's
where at the end i'm just basically like
like just passing out as i'm reading
these things
all right
all right so lisa is in the chat she's
appeared yes lisa i am at my parents
house
which is why i am here and my father
appeared in the camera i'm actually with
my brother dan who none of you people
have never some of you never probably
heard of but dan her brother was a
professional skateboarder
and uh a really good one too he's one of
the top in the world for a while
dan pedro to come up
and uh and then he became a pastor and
now he's a protestant pastor so
all right so drew mcmahon says hi
jonathan have you ever seen pan's
labyrinth so if i'm curious about your
thoughts see pack with symbolism if you
have not seen it here's my backup
question can you talk about the
symbolism of wristwatches thank you
so i have seen it
but
i saw it a very long time ago
probably when it just came out
and uh it didn't have that strong of an
impact on me
i felt i think like it to me it felt too
linked
to something like the nazis
uh
and like world war ii or whatever it was
like the the it was too linked to some
specific historical moment that i found
it
difficult
and so what is the symbolism of ridge
watches
well for sure the idea of a
watch that's also or the idea of a time
teller that's also an ornament is
definitely related right if you read
matthew's book you'll see how the idea
that that
you would have an ornament that
spins and tells you time
it's pretty good symbolism in terms of
what what ornamentation is and what you
know this what time
represents in terms of
of uh circular causality
and lack of point you know pointless um
turning
yeah
so sean desmond
says in catholicism we have a concept
called the seven gifts of the holy
spirit
based on isaiah 11.
three of these gifts are knowledge
understanding and wisdom
can you comment on what distinguishes
these three orders of intellect
yeah
so the way at least that i that i
understand it this is the way that i
understand it and uh
it's a little tricky so i
understanding seems to be something like
something like a bunch of facts like
an accumulation of knowledge so you
accumulate a bunch of knowledge
and
wisdom seems to be
something like the spirit
something like
the spirit in which these facts can be
can be
accumulated
something like that
like the
the applicability
itself the applicability of those facts
the reason why i wouldn't even care for
them
then knowledge seems to be the union of
the two
so knowledge would be heaven and earth
meaning something like that right it's a
sexual union between understanding and
wisdom
that's my understanding of it and i
think like a lot of it came from
discussions i had with my brother matsir
so
so you might get more insights
about that in this book as well
alright so alejandro
dorado asks
i jonathan a divine comedy there's this
idea that in the highest place in heaven
is the trinity where the multiplicity of
persons merge as one identity this being
the very pattern of how things exist
symbolically you talked about this idea
when you're talks is the idea of satan
eating the
the three main traitors
of history the opposite image
what
oh
okay in dante where the multiplicity
becomes a place of disintegration and
ultimately an image of death never
thought about that maybe
maybe
there was part of one body but gave a
higher place to their idiosyncrasies
than to the higher goal head of the body
part or love causing death or
disintegration
um well i don't know about the trinity
but for sure there's there's definitely
supposed to be a connection
between the difference between
let's say let's say dante
being sublimated into
into the divinity into the divine being
carried up
into the love that binds all things
together
that's how it ends um
and that it's something like beyond
beyond words beyond expression
um
being carried up into the love that
binds all things together and
this kind of being chewed by the devil
like being
being mixed and
broken down into your constitutive
elements like i
think for sure that that is definitely
the way that dante wanted to to to
structure his story so
yeah good catch there
david overby asked you said not too long
ago that one of your biggest fears is
goddess worship creeping into
christianity my question is why do you
think that is such a deep human impulse
and what should
the proper response be
um
so i think that
the reason why it's such a deep human
impulse is that
we know that all things that exist or
that all things that present themselves
hide
some aspect of
of god
and so all things reveal to us the glory
of god and so there seems to be a
mystery
in the fact that god is presented as
being in heaven that god is presented as
being
um
the father
and
there is
an inevitable
like mystical drive towards
transcending that duality we could say
and also perceiving
god in the other term
and so and i think that that is
inevitable and there's something about
that which is not wrong
uh but i think
the problem is that
the very nature of the feminine is to v
avail itself right the very nature of
the feminine is to hide
and so i and i feel like
christianity has
in some ways
captured the right
attitude towards it which is
a reverence
moving towards a kind of eschatological
union so the idea is that
in the end
we will be as the body of christ we will
be deified you know as the body of
christ we will become god to the extent
that that is possible
and so the idea is that
the mystery of
the feminine is eschatological and so
should not be
stated it should be
hoped for hinted at um
you know side in the direction of i
don't know what else to say
uh and so i feel like the desire to
to uncover the virgin right it's
like i feel like that is is a as a
transgression that is
that is very dangerous
yeah i don't know how to say what i'm
saying here
all right so anders browse that says hi
jonathan
in your recent conversation with john
jordan and john you discussed the
primacy of narrative can you still man
john zuein point to where you've used
the part
also when would the exodus seminar drop
yeah november that's when it's dropping
so yeah i think john really
i think john really expressed his
position very powerfully and uh
and i and i think that i've been
thinking about it ever since you know
and i'm hoping to have more discussion
with him about that
there i think that
this what he would he's describing is
that
there is a
anomalogical order of beings that is
there is
so let's say like the relationship of
beings to each other in categories
is not
narrative
right it has its own
existence and that existence is the
categorization of scientific categories
it's it's something like laws it's
something like
you know
genealogies or whatever like there these
these
these
structures exist and they themselves are
not narrative and they have a value so i
think that
he's right and and i think that
it should i think it's probably
important
not to
confuse
the narrative
with the nomological
uh
so to me that is the best case of what
he's making
and and i think that he's right
that there's no doubt about that
now but
here's the but
i think that
one of the things that wasn't addressed
in that discussion is that i believe
that the nomological order
has to be teleological
that
even the nomological order has to be
ordered in
reasons why those categories exist
that it's not just about a neutral
categorization
but that the categories are embedded in
a in a in a hierarchy of reasons
and so
i think i haven't asked john directly
but i think he would probably agree with
that
um
and that if he agrees with that jordan
actually
man
jordan actually said something very
powerful in that discussion which just
went by and it's like i don't think i
even noticed it
on that evening and then i rewatched it
and i was like jordan caught on to
something
and he said
he said science
is if
then
and so he says the if
is narrative
and the then is nommological and i was
like and i was rewatching and i was like
oh man that is so
powerful
it's like
so the nomological order
is teleological
but i still do think that that the
teleology
is anchored in purposes
and because those purposes
cannot help but be
human purposes we could say
ultimately
that i think that it still makes the
case for
for say maximus's position
and also it makes the case for
the if has to be bound in a kind of
story
that is
why do i care about this
in the first place like
but if i want to do this then that is
then this is the categorization because
beings have indefinite angles and
definite possibilities of how to
to to to to come to them right there's
so it's like
the restraining
of the facts that you need
the restraining of
the external
parameters that you need in order to
attain the nomological order
does nonetheless i don't see how it
can't be
bound in the human story
now it doesn't mean that the other one
that the nomological order is
completely vanishes in front of the
other one like it means that it has its
own real kind of existence but i think
you see it
so you can see it
in the
in the story of exodus right so it's
like the law is presented
in
a story
and so you can see it in the story of
genesis so in genesis there is a
nomological order which is presented
right at the outset
of
the bible so god
sets up like you could create the
hierarchy of beings with the you know
with the the stars and the sun and the
moon and the
you know and the birds and so there's
this order of being and it goes all the
way down to chaos and all the way up
towards towards heaven um
but it is
bound in a story of
conscious
seeing and
evaluating the good
and it ultimately is created at least in
the christian understanding it
ultimately all this ends up being
created
for man in the middle and to
for man to be the one who
mediates between all of this
and his story so
that's the best i could do for now but
yeah it was
it's actually really helped me to be a
little baby hopefully be more subtle
and more careful in the way that i talk
about things so
yeah john's good for that for sure he's
he's really brilliant so
all right guys
it is past 10 and so i'm reaching my the
end of my uh my rope
so guys i'm going to uh i'm going to
sign off
and uh sorry for the bad camera
but the bad camera uh it's a
the bad camera image in this one but um
but we'll see you guys next month again
thanks for everybody who continues to
continue to support me despite the
absolute
craziness that is around us besides
watching inflation and
energy prices go up besides everybody
talking about
starvation
you know it's like it drives me crazy
like it
just makes me so angry especially
if we all said it at the outset when
they started all the cogan nonsense like
we all said it we said
this is going to lead towards mass
starvation
and here we are like the un put out a
paper just last week
saying they've upped their numbers the
people they're going to starve it's not
going to be 100 million it's going to be
350 million
and uh you know
and now they can blame
they can blame the war in russia which
i'm sure is part of it but
yeah
so
yeah so let us carry on folks and thanks
for your attention everybody thanks for
everything and i will see you next month
bye